[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
derek chauvin's sentence to 22 and a
half years in prison
for the murder of george floyd or what
the sentence is not based on
is emotion or sympathy
george floyd's family speaks out and we
hear for the first time from derek
shawn's mother
when you sentence my son
you will also be sentencing me plus
heartbreaking testimony in the murder
trial of mark redwine
an attorney says she gave the legal
advice that allowed 13-year-old dylan
to go to his father before he was
murdered he wanted to live with his
mother
and the former saturday night live cast
member pressed on the stand
in the robert durst trial is the actress
and comedian
a key to a false alibi i was ashamed
that as i've said before that i didn't
appreciate the gravity
of what she was saying to me law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm brian ross in our studios in
new york
brian buckmeyer is on assignment in
minneapolis for the sentencing of derek
shovin
and also with us here in new york as
always co-host terry austin
22 and a half years that's the sentence
judge peter cahill
handed down to derek shoven
the court commits you to the custody of
the commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 270
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence of
150 months this is based on
your abuse of a position of trust and
authority
and also the particular cruelty shown to
george floyd
brian buckmeyer in minneapolis that's 10
years more than what the
guidelines would call for but much less
than what the prosecutors had asked for
30 years
absolutely many people here after
hearing the sentence
felt that it was too low of a sentence
many people
getting angry no violence but just
shouting
in frustration that they wanted more
people were definitely asking for the 40
years hoping that judge k
will go beyond what the prosecution
recommended but
many disappointed in 22 and a half years
right well this all came after the judge
heard from george floyd's
family starting with floyd's now
seven-year-old daughter gianna
she spoke about how she hopes the world
remembers her father
well they helped him because
some of those mean people did something
to
him yeah if you could say anything to
your daddy right now what would it be
it would be i miss you and i love you
i wanted to know from the man himself
why
what were you thinking what was going
through your head
when you had your knee on my brother's
neck we seek
the massive maximum penalty
we don't want to see no more slaps on
the wrists
had a real nice sleep because of the
nightmares i constantly have hearing my
brother big
and plead for his life over and over
again
even saying they going to kill me
please officer screaming for our mom
i i have had to sit through each day
of officer derrick sheldon's trial and
watched the video
of george dying for hours over and over
again
and for the defense only one person
spoke on behalf of derrick shovin
his mother she says her son is not a
racist
and that she will always love him
my son's identity has also been reduced
to that as of that as
a racist
i want this court to know
that none of these things are true
remember there is no stronger bond
or love than a mother's love
one final thought i want you to remember
remember you are my favorite son
and then finally before he was sentenced
derek chauvin briefly addressed the
court with a cryptic
message to floyd's family
at this time due to some additional
legal matters at hand
i'm not able to give a full formal
statement at this time
um but very briefly though
i do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
um there's going to be some other
information
in the future that would be of interest
and
uh i hope things will give you some
some peace of mind thank you
terry austin this is the first time
we've heard from derek schilling other
than his decision not to testify
what did you make of that message he was
sending what he had to say
you know brian i think this was a missed
opportunity he spoke for less than a
minute
and he made reference to these
additional legal matters we know that's
the federal indictment he's talking
about
and the good news is he did give the
condolences to the floyd family that's
the first thing that he should do and he
did do that
but this cryptic message that's exactly
the right word that you used
about additional comments hoping that it
would bring
peace to the family it's unclear what he
meant by that i guess he has written
something that the family will
eventually see
but i think it was a missed opportunity
he could have been
a bit more remorseful in a statement
probably cold comfort for the floyd
family brian what was the reaction
outside the courthouse
when the sentence came down for 22 and a
half years
it was mixed we had an opportunity to
speak with george floyd's
uh girlfriend courtney ross and
her reaction was that she was
disappointed with the 22 and a half
years
but also she heard the screams and the
cries for violence and outbursts and
anger
over the sentencing in 22 and a half
years and the lack of message
from derek shovin and so she was asking
for calm
peace and to not take george floyd's
name in vain so to speak
in any attacks towards violence i do
understand that
derek chovin didn't give more words but
i think that's because he's got
litigation coming to federal court
and i think he's hinting at maybe giving
more because there may be a plea deal
that get worked out soon
with derrick shoven and the federal
government where you might hear more
sympathetic
feedback from brian under minnesota law
22 and a half years could be reduced by
as much as a third isn't that right
it actually is absolutely going to be
reduced unless he does something
incorrect while incarcerated for every
two days he serves in jail he gets one
day of jail time
so 22 and a half years he'll do about 14
years in jail
he was accredited about 190 days about
two-thirds of a year
for the time already served so he'll be
in jail for about 14 years but again
the feds are coming after him with
another case and those that
those years will be tacked on top of any
state time all right so he could be out
as early as age 60 depending on the
federal case
thanks much still ahead on law and crime
daily
behind judge cahill's reasoning for
derrick chauvin's sentence
plus a colorado father on trial for the
murder of his own son the witness
breaking down on the stand
talking about the life of dylan redwine
and what led to his death
[Music]
welcome back the world was watching as
judge peter cahill made his decision on
derrick chauvin's sentence
explaining it had nothing to do with
sympathy or emotion
i have a 22-page memorandum that is
going to be attached to the sentencing
order
and why am i doing it in writing to
emphasize the fact that
determining the appropriate sentence in
any case
and in this case is a legal analysis
it's applying the rule of law to the
facts of an individual
and specific case
in his presentation defense attorney
eric nelson spoke about chauvin's
service in the military
commitments to his friends and family
and says he lived an honorable life
nelson then gave some insights into
chauvin's frame of mind
derek shovin was not even scheduled to
work on may 25th
2020. he volunteered because there was
short staffing at the time
i know from numerous conversations that
i've had with derek
that his brain is littered with what-ifs
what if i just had not agreed to go in
that day
what if things had gone differently what
if i never responded to that call
what if what if what if
prosecutors had asked for 30 years and
assistant minnesota attorney general
matthew frank
even became choked up thanking the
witnesses for testifying
including members of the law enforcement
community
under great pressure great stress to
some extent
apparel to their their occupations
what they've devoted their life to
stuck to their oath and their commitment
as police officers
to speak openly and honestly
about policing and the training
that is given and received by police
officers
those officers didn't hide behind a blue
wall
they came forward they told this court
and those jurors
so brian buckmeyer matthew frank
appeared to choke up when he spoke about
this case there were
strong and raw emotions on both sides
today weren't there
absolutely from the family of george
floyd and the prosecution
they spoke about how the loss of a
father or brother uh just an individual
affected them and of course like any
mother uh
would derek shove his mother took the
stand and spoke about
how this was affecting her life and i
think it was slightly a missed
opportunity not to acknowledge
that the other family had literally lost
someone and that she was simply going to
have
some difficulty in communicating with
her son while others
their son was dead but i still think it
was heartfelt on both sides
regardless of how you looked at it and
terry austin the judge expressed great
sympathy to the floyd family did he
strike the right balance on what he said
though about
ruling out emotion and sympathy in
making his decision
well he was very clear he did not want
any emotion or sympathy to affect the
eventual sentence he said he wanted to
apply the law to the facts and that was
it
he wanted his 22-page memorandum to
speak for itself
what that tells me is that he had
already prepared
the memorandum and he had already made
his decision
based on the law and the facts so i
think he struck the right balance as far
as the decision was concerned
he took the guidelines and he actually
added the additional 150 months
based on the abuse and cruelty and
that's how he got to the 270. so
that made sense to me i do wish he had
said a little more i think people
wanted to hear from him but i guess
we'll have to read the 20-day
memorandum to see exactly what his
thoughts were
and brian mcmahon did leave you wanting
more to hear from him too
absolutely i think that he could have
given a lot a little bit more
i mean we've seen cases like this i
think of the botham jean case
where the judge gave a little bit more
in talking about the loss of the victim
but also the defense i would have hoped
for a little bit more than that but as
terry said we might have to look to that
22-page memorandum
to see what his thoughts really were on
the issue fascinating reading for that
all right coming up on law on crime
daily more from the former snl star on
the stand
in the robert durst trial plus
riveting testimony in the trial the
teenage boy found murder
in colorado what his parents divorce
attorney
had to say that's next
[Music]
testimony in the trial of mark redwine
has now turned to his relationship with
the son he's accused of murdering and
his temper
long crimes anjanet levy has the latest
anjanette
by all accounts dylan redwine did not
want to visit his father over the
thanksgiving weekend
in 2012 but a lawyer for dylan's mother
told the jury
dylan had no choice he wanted to live
with his mother
amber harrison represented dylan
redwine's mother in her divorce
she testified a couple of months before
dylan disappeared
a judge granted his mother's request to
move to colorado springs
and ordered that thanksgiving 2012 visit
between mark redwine and dylan
i told her that she had to put dylan on
the plane
or she would be charged with contempt of
court harrison
also testified about what dylan told her
about his father
he was uncomfortable around his father
he disclosed to me that he had seen
the pictures that creeped them out
and made him feel very uncomfortable
mark redwine's attorney implied that
harrison was biased and never documented
dylan's feelings about the photos
do you recall that one of the issues
that was
in contention was claims by mr redwine
that
elaine hall was alienating him from
dylan
i believe that was one of mr redwine's
claims yes
kathy berry a friend of elaine halls
told the jury about an encounter she and
another woman had when confronting mark
redwine
about his feces fetish he picked up that
that log
and he didn't like like this and all i
remember was
i don't know if you've ever seen the
cartoon where the eyes bulge out and all
you can see
in the white of the eyes but that's all
i saw the defense tried to discredit
barry's account
you and denise acknowledge that you
provoked mr redwine is that right
i believe those words came out of the
mouth of denise hess
and you both knew you shouldn't have
provoked him right
i didn't know that did anybody at any
point ever tell you what happened with a
crime
no the jurors also saw a reconstruction
of mark redwine's home that had been
erected in the courthouse
prosecutors say that that home had
undergone
extensive renovation following a fire
and that november 2012 visit by dylan
was his first since that work had been
done
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
turning now to other top legal news
making headlines
the donald trump organization reportedly
could face criminal charges
the new york times broke the story that
the manhattan district attorney's office
has informed former president donald
trump's lawyers
that they are considering charges
against the company as soon as next week
the da's office is investigating trump's
family's business
for alleged fringe benefits the company
awarded a top executive
without paying taxes the charges would
be a first for the investigation to
trump
and his former business dealings when we
come back a former snl star faces
cross-examination
what she has to say about her dear
friend the murder victim
and the shame and guilt she felt from
withholding information from
investigators
more to come in the trial of robert
durst
and welcome back continuing coverage now
of the trial of real estate air robert
durst
we're hearing more from the former
saturday night live cast member lorraine
newman
robert durst is accused of murdering his
best friend susan berman in december
2000.
friends of susan berman have been taking
the stand but none stand out quite like
lorraine newman
newman is best known for her role as
connie conehead during her tenure
on snl on cross-examination defense
attorneys questioned newman about
berman's dramatic tendencies and why the
comedian
withheld information from investigators
when they first reached out to her
it was hard to know what was true and
what wasn't
correct there were times yes and you
also told mr lewin
that there came a point in time where
susan rescinded her story about the
alibi
remember that yes that means took it
back
another reason that you told mr lewin
you didn't tell anybody about it
was because susan was so capable of
hyperbole
that you didn't even know what she may
or may not have told you
was the truth i i said that
yes you did okay
on redirect newman expressed her shame
to prosecutor john lewin about
withholding information
mr chesnov asked you if in fact you had
said something that you weren't really
sure if you had anything valuable or
substantive to offer do you remember
that question
yes i do i was ashamed that
as i've said before that i didn't
appreciate the gravity
of what she was saying to me and that i
blithely accepted her backtracking and
rescinding
and it was almost like i think i said
this to you at the time like
the kitty genovese crime where people
watched
as this girl was stabbed to death and
did nothing
returning now to the sentencing of derek
shoven and reaction from george floyd's
girlfriend courtney ross who talked with
our brian buckmeyer
outside the courthouse i believed
that it was going to be 40 i thought he
was going to do the max sentence so
i i am disappointed but people's
reaction
what did you want to say about people's
reaction and what george floyd would
have wanted
right now um i will say this loud and
clear
anyone who is preaching violence anyone
who is preaching hurting other people
that i have heard around here
this is the wrong place to do it do not
do it in floyd's name that is not what
he was ever about he was about peace and
love and inclusion
and helping people ryan buckmeyer that
was a strong message from courtney ross
to uh followers of this case
absolutely courtney ross was here uh
even like an hour or two before
the verdict or sorry the sentence was
read out and she was here playing with
children don't forget she's a
schoolteacher
playing with children talking to people
she was so happy to speak with us
and so adamant that she did not want
people
taking george floyd's name and using it
towards violence
however she was very reflective of the
22 and a half years
and didn't feel that it was enough but
she felt it was a step forward in some
way shape or form
uh but she was very adamant about this
needing to be a time of reconciliation
peace and not violence
and terry austin what's the message you
think the sentencing today sends to the
three other
minneapolis police officers who were on
the scene that day
you know i think they have to be
concerned that when their trial
commences
in march of 2022 they
might be facing similar sentences as we
saw today
especially the two who were involved in
holding
george floyd down so we know that
alexander king and thomas lane were both
on the back and legs respectively and i
think
there was evidence and medical testimony
about the fact that that did contribute
at least as far as
being on the back to george floyd's
death i think
tutao who was the individual who was
keeping the
individuals at bay and making sure they
didn't interfere
i think he should be concerned as well
we might see some pleas taken here
because they may really want to avoid a
conviction
and they may not want to be an example
and so
i think there's that possibility that's
how i think the sentence
will affect those cases so brian
buckmeyer more to come in this case it's
not quite over
absolutely and don't forget there are
also federal charges that are pending
kind of got a glimpse of what may come
from that cryptic message that uh derek
shovin
shared with us but also the other three
facing their state and potential federal
charges as well
all right thank you so much and thank
you all for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time
as we continue to discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you